the chicago bears have won five out of
six
and no matter what they do they're not
being taken seriously and
you know what this is the perfect way
for the circumstances to come together
for a coach because you don't have to
worry about your guys getting a big head
because no one's saying or doing
anything that would give them a big head
and then you use the fact that people
aren't giving you the respect that you
deserve
to motivate your guys to go out and keep
winning now the schedule
gets a little bit tougher starting on
monday night with the game against the
rams and then the saints and then at the
titans so we're gonna learn a lot about
the bears over the next three weeks
but for them to be five and one sharim
do we need to be taking them
more seriously than we currently are
oh probably but you know i compare it to
two years ago i didn't take them real
seriously either and they were a clank
field goal double doink off the field
goal from advancing in the
postseason but i just nothing's been
real impressive i mean detroit's two and
three the giants one and five the
falcons one and five okay the bucks
that was a good win at four and two and
maybe if brady didn't forget the downs
maybe they lose that game
panthers three and three you know they
lost the colts who were
four foreign too so their next five to
me are going to tell
me exactly where this team is and maybe
they're better than i think they are
because i'm one of those who's not
giving them the respect perhaps
that they're due and you know we heard
nick foles say well i'd rather win ugly
than lose pretty
hey i want to win pretty and there are a
lot of teams in this league winning
pretty right now and they're not one of
them and so when you start
talking about teams you think are going
to contend they're certainly not
one i put in that category yeah i think
the list goes
lose ugly lose pretty win ugly
win pretty because winning ugly is not
sustainable
because if you are winning by the skin
of your teeth if you're relying upon
flukes if you're relying upon
the greatest quarterback of all time
losing track of the downs
eventually that's going to catch up to
you over the course of a 16 game season
but here's nick foles from sunday
and this is spirited and this is
passionate and it's inspiring and it's
something that
everyone needs to be listening to
because this is a guy who was a super
bowl mvp he's the consummate leader and
teammate
he's doing what he can to will this team
to be better than the sum of the parts
here he is from yesterday
we're not gonna get complacent and say
hey man we're five and one this is it no
like we're sitting there in the locker
room after the game talking through it
hey we gotta be better here this is what
we gotta do here
communication here route running here
hey we gotta be able to run the ball
here we know that
i know you are gonna ask those questions
we know that and that's what's exciting
because we don't have to have y'all say
hey you're doing this hey we know but we
also know that we're going to improve
because we believe in one another and
that's what great teams do great teams
find a way to win a game
bad teams win with prettiness great
teams
win no matter how it takes so i'm proud
of our guys
i i i think we're continuing to improve
are we where we want to be no we're not
where we want to be but i'm excited
about our offense i'm like
excited about the guys that are there i
like the communication that's happening
on silent i love the passion of the
players
most important they care and we're
bonding we're getting to know each other
that's football like you don't just go
out there and play football
you got to care about the man next to
you to make those plays
so i like where we're at i know we're
going to improve
i believe in our staff i believe in our
players and i'm really grateful to be a
part of this organization
it just cracks me up to see him talk
like that he's got the demeanor the guy
who ordered decaf and accidentally got
regular
it's just great i love it i love it and
and that's
and that's you know that's the best
thing about the bears right now they
made the decision to go with foals when
they were
down uh in a game that uh they
ultimately came back and won
he lost the colts game but he's beaten
the bucks and now
he's beating the panthers who were
favored to win which i thought played
into the bear's hands
and we're going to find out like i said
rams saints titans we're going to find
out if this team is built to last
shereen
yeah that that's exactly right and
really their next five games ram saints
titans vikings and packers
and so that's that's really a tough
stretch there i mean there's one game
there
they're going to be favored again don't
don't
don't try it don't try to make me feel
one game they know they know what they
are
that's a monday night game two in
chicago i don't give the viking a
snowball's chance in uh on the equator
to have a chance at that one which
probably means they'll win the way mud
luck's been going picking games this
year but look at the schedule leave that
up please
they're they're five and one right now
through six games ten games left
which means all you gotta do is go five
and five and you're ten and six
all right so vikings lions texans
vikings jaguars there's your five wins
you can get swept by the packers
you can lose to the titans you can lose
to the rams you can lose to the saints
you can still be ten and six and uh
that's a pretty damn good season for
these bears
and i think i think that's the minimum
right now
well and they need to win the division
mike to get a home field advantage and
we know it's hard to win in
chicago in january it's cold and if you
get one of those indoor teams or a warm
weather team it's going to
be really hard to win there i'll i'll
say this
their defense is good enough to keep
them in every single game they're going
to be in every single game they're not
going to get blown out of games
and i think that's what they really have
worked for them they're seventh in
defense and when you look over there and
you see
khalil mack on the other side you know
they're going to get after people when
you
and you better be you have your best
foot forward
on offense to compete with that defense
because you're just not going to score a
lot of points and when you get your
chances you better take advantage of it
but that defense
is legit i think but they need to get
the offense going
and it you know maybe you find a running
back somewhere but i think they need a
running back
they're 28th in rushing 28th and overall
offense but they've got to get the
running game going
especially again if we're talking about
winning a playoff game in cold weather
you got to be able to run the ball and
right now this is a team that's
averaging under 100 yards as a team
running the ball every week
you mentioned the next five games will
be a challenge the fifth game you saw it
on the schedule a little peacock logo
next to it a sunday night game
thanksgiving weekend on nbc bears and
packers get together that should be a
great one because it's very rare
that both of those teams are great at
the same time and this year
they both look great notwithstanding
what happened to the packers yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports